good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast stand happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down on Friday
that's right everyone congratulations
you made it to Friday acknowledge the
space that you're in the weekend is
ahead of us there's so much hope on the
horizon you can call me hopio today hey
Jax how you doing
Hope on the horizon I'd love that for us
I'm darn great just enjoying the season
that we're in we need to acknowledge the
space that we're in which is
the holiday season and it's before
Thanksgiving everything is ahead of us
The Vibes are Immaculate the chili is on
the stove the weather is crisp really
wherever you are because we're catching
a nice breeze here in Florida too chill
so it must be nice I wouldn't say chill
I would say Brie a wind a gust of wind
um so it must be nice for lots of people
except for those in Western New York
where there's a huge snowstorm coming
through unprecedented they say so stay
safe out there
stay safe um six feet they say I'm
hoping we get like one foot
yeah but this is like all the way up in
Buffalo so we probably should remain
unaffected here but don't forget to make
a chili before the snow comes I think
that's a huge huge lesson in
preparedness it's true because it really
like chili holds so well it actually
gets better like the longer it's in the
fridge and the freezer it's just a
suggestion a little just
a suggestion
um it's Friday I think that's such such
a big deal
um that we should really really talk
about personally like I worked last
weekend because I'd show so I haven't
had a weekend I'm in two weeks not to
make Friday about me I'm just like
really feeling like I need this weekend
you know what are you gonna do with your
weekend that's the thing I have like a
few plans here and there but like
nothing crazy I'm really looking forward
to a nice blend of catching up on some
TV watch uh what
reading books seeing friends maybe
having a cocktail or two
um it's just it's exciting it's
thrilling I'm honored to be here and I'm
wishing everyone the same kind of
weekend energy that that I'm hoping for
yes godspeed and for those of us
prepping for Thanksgiving now would be a
good time to test some recipes that
you're not sure about I might try out my
Mac and Cheese just to make sure it's
the right mac and cheese well if you
want the right mac and cheese just get
it from a box because I never tasted a
mac and cheese at a restaurant or from
someone's kitchen that was better than
anything I found in a box of craft wacky
Mac Annie's any of those things
the Weight Watchers one don't sleep on
the Weight Watchers mac and cheese
because that [ __ ] is fire I agree with
that but also it's kind of fun to make
mac and cheese that's not something
that's super laborious it's like mixing
the cheeses boiling pasta it's really
easy no but I'm not saying because it's
hard I'm saying because it's never as
good
like if I went to a Thanksgiving meal
and they had a big old bowl of Kraft mac
and cheese I would be like Michelin star
for everyone James Beard brass mac and
cheese is so delicious and they won't
contest you on that but to have a big
bowl of it in addition to everything
else it's a little sickening in the
literal sense no since that's another
word that we've completely abused
because I would say it's sickening
okay then you should do that for your
Thanksgiving no I definitely will
request it wherever I'm going
and it's not going to be here oh you
guys I'm so excited I feel like I'm
living two lives right now because I'm
just like sharing my life on my
Instagram and then I have to like come
on this show and I forget everything
that I've been sharing but because I
already shared it you know well so
that's like a a thing that like
so you really like
just with Harry and like being pregnant
like you really stopped being so active
on Instagram and now that you know
you're literally Kylie like I feel like
I'm getting my personality back you're
obviously now like becoming more active
on Instagram and it's a weird line to
draw when like you want to share what
you already shared on the podcast on
Instagram because most people have
already seen it so you don't know if you
want to be like repetitive well it's not
about being repetitive for me the issue
is once I've shared it somewhere it's
like okay it's shared I don't need to
remember to say it on the show do you
know what I mean but yesterday my dining
table arrived which is something I need
to shout from the rooftops because I've
been waiting for it for months it came
in time for Thanksgiving it's a
Thanksgiving miracle and I'm so excited
it's crazy how excited you get about
furniture when you're an adult like I
never thought I'd be so excited about
the arrival of a dining table no because
like living in a house that doesn't have
a basic like a dining room table a couch
those are cornerstones of a home and so
whether you're in an apartment or
whatever like not having like a
Cornerstone piece is so annoying yeah so
I'm so excited to get my Thanksgiving
show on the road and now I can like
start setting my table I haven't found
the right centerpiece yet for the
holiday festivities so what about a
picture of me enrolled
no I don't think so I think so since
you're not gonna be there I think I
should just focus on the people who are
present so maybe it'll be like a picture
of me Olivia Zack Zack Michaela rolled
in Levi and Bruno and then on the side a
picture of like me and the kids
maybe I'll see if that's what they want
just I feel like it would really boost
the Thanksgiving ruach
and then last night I cooked a delicious
meal do you see it you would have loved
it salmon teriyaki with rice you didn't
see on my Instagram no isn't it rude
when somebody doesn't watch the content
that you worked really hard on it was
just a picture you didn't have to watch
anything then I must be delayed
you message me and now you know just a
smidgen of the hurt I felt over the last
two years where you explicitly told me
you don't listen to my story as a sound
here's the thing two things one if
there's captions that's really helpful
and two if it's just a video with no
even like caption about like what this
video is about I'm probably not gonna
watch it and that's it goes same for me
if I post a video with no captions and
no one-liner about what you can expect
to be hearing in this video then I don't
expect you to have to watch it I will
understand I would never do that to
someone else
not to somebody I admire and respect but
maybe you don't admire and respect me
maybe maybe I think that I do
I mean we'll never know
I think we know
I think we'll never know I think anybody
who listens to the show can tell you
that I have so much admiration and
respect for you wait so that's nice that
you made cemeteryaki but it does pale in
comparison to what I got to do last
night
um which was sit down and interview a
holocaust Survivor not that it's like a
competition of our night and also like
that was like kind of in the afternoon
no it was actually at five o'clock so
that's no you sent the picture or when
it was done I hadn't even started
cooking so it's like not no it was it
was literally like I left that place at
like 5 30. so because you had done it in
the afternoon but okay no because it
literally started at 4 30 so like that's
the evening
um it's actually it's a gray area for
sure let's let's just call it that
um it was amazing I was obsessed with
this man and he's obviously dedicated
his life to Holocaust like awareness and
education because when I posted a
picture of us on Instagram like so many
people messaged me like oh my God he
spoke at my college oh my God he spoke
at my school so he's like doing the
Lord's work and he started he's so cute
so he like is retired and he worked in
jewelry and he came to this country with
like five literally five dollars he
lived in Poland after the Holocaust and
lived under communist Rule and he was
like I mean it wasn't ideal but compared
to the Nazis like it was Freedom
eventually they uh they were offering
like citizenship to polish Jews to
Israel
um after Israel was created as a state
and so him and his family moved there
and he had been studying law in Poland
and his sister had been studying
medicine and when they moved to Israel
she continued to study medicine but
their dad was killed in the war so he
had to provide for the family so he
never got to you know finish his
education as a lawyer and then after
working in Israel for so long and
supporting his family he wanted to move
to America so he came to New York he
said his mom gave him five dollars and
put him on a boat and he came here he
didn't speak the language he you know
one of his cousins like knew someone got
him a job being a janitor in um a
factory that made jewelry and he slowly
over the years worked his way up in this
Factory that he was a manager and then
he heard about this smaller Factory
coming up for for sale he was able to
buy it started his own business it's
like really the American dream and he
has since retired and he has devoted his
life now to Holocaust Education his
granddaughters are toasters like I can't
um
and he has a foundation called The Mark
schoenwetter Foundation that um it was a
lot honestly like when he's telling me
about it I never heard of a better
foundation in my life they just raise
money and then they give these money in
Grants to schools that don't have the
resources to teach kids about the
Holocaust um so it provides like yeah
funding for like materials books uh
curriculum and now I'm obsessed with
this Foundation like I I'm gonna do a
fundraiser like I was like his daughter
runs a foundation I was like you just
have to let me like raise money
um and so I just want to prepare
everyone like I will be Hawking you all
for money sometime soon
um I'm gonna be like texting every rich
person I know being like I will never
talk to you again unless you donate five
thousand dollars so I am so excited
about that so I just want everyone to be
prepared to get your wallets out oh I
love that you have free reign to talk
about as much as you want on this show
and I would love to help you in any way
that I can no like I'm we're gonna I
wanna my goal like as tour is a hundred
thousand dollars which I think is like a
lot but I think we can do it and let's
do it let's do it
um so it's just a really fast where can
we see this interview so it looks come
out it's a part of a series of videos
being released on Hanukkah so it's like
one for each night I am one night me and
Mark
um it'll be all up on my Instagram
tonight we share as we like shed to
remind us we'll go we share a sweet
light I think it's shed but like that
makes it how would you shed light oh we
you could be like you shed light
emanating no I definitely maybe it is
shed
one for each night we shed a sweet light
to remind us of days long ago honestly
Hanukkah music does not happening
that's funny
but we'll give you a treat
to play with it
we are playing the candles are burning
bright one for each night we shed a
sweet light to remind us of days long
ago one for each night we shed as we
like to remind us of days long ago no
like if they play that song in the club
oh my God I would not be okay that song
Bops I totally forgot about it because
everyone when they think of Hanukkah
music they do the classic Dreidel
Dreidel Dreidel it's good it's for the
kids you know it's it's it's okay then
you also think of Adam Sandler which is
cute but really nothing slaps quite like
a good old-fashioned klezmer version
Taylor's version
and if you do it with like a Yiddish
accent oh man and Mark spoke Yiddish and
he was like making him teach me all
these phrases because it's a forgotten
language it was just an amazing
afternoon evening
yeah so you agree
you gasped at me no is it amazing it's
actually hard to tell what's evening and
what's afternoon in the winter you know
what else is Gaslight a menorah go get
yourself one and publicize The Nest yes
Hanukkah is coming up but let's talk
about it is Hanukkah such a good
question every year different it's
different you know we go by the Jewish
calendar which means that Hanukkah lands
on a different day on the English
calendar lunar you know I'm actually
going to look this up just in case I
need to start do you find me presents
I I haven't gotten your present yet but
I've gotten for everyone else December
18th oh it's the 18th until the 26th so
it's like really in the Christmas season
that's nice so we can be included we'll
be so included I kind of liked having it
like separate like I know like we're
special however I'm not gonna complain
um so we've got a great show lots to
discuss I'm really excited to get into
the Ticketmaster of it all because
there's so much going on I don't know if
you know all that's going on
um and I feel like I'm gonna come at it
with like a really healthy and non-toxic
point of view which is a rarity in the
Swifty Community right now because
people have lost their damn Minds yeah
so without further Ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know
I think you should have said without
further a foo
are you for real because today's episode
is sponsored bye
um
that's right today's episode is
sponsored by thuma your bedroom deserves
a refresh and now is the perfect time to
elevate the most important room in your
home with thuma I think we all can you
know point to an experience in our lives
where we have had major frustrations you
know contemplating divorce when it comes
to setting up furniture that has to be
assembled but them is different they're
not like other Furniture companies and
the bed by thuma which is handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood you'll find beautiful unique
variations in the natural grain the
minimalist design which features
Japanese joinery helps Elevate any space
it's super supportive for your mattress
it's breathable and it's made to
naturally minimize noise and create
space so in terms of assembly the bed
comes in three easy to maneuver boxes
which is not a lot for a big old bed and
it's super easy to assemble five-ish
minutes no tools required and it's
easily buildable yourself and the
perfect platform bed frame just got
better because you can now customize the
bed by choosing between the original
pillow board or their new solid wood
headboard based on whatever Vibe you're
rowing for in your room the fabric
pillow board adds softness and color to
a space while the headboard offers solid
Sleek support the headboard attaches
directly to the bed using Japanese
joinery so no tools are required and you
can buy it with the bed or on its own as
an upgrade fuma practice is an
intentional less is more design
philosophy so that means clean lines
subtle curves and lifestyle enhancing
details they also work with one tree
planted over at thuma they plant every
trip they plant one tree for every bed
and nightstand sold all of their
Essentials are green guard gold
certified create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
fuma now go to thuma.co toast to receive
a 25 credit towards your purchase of the
bed plus free shipping in the
continental US go to thuma.co toast
that's t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash toast for
the 25 dollar credit
okay ready for our first story
Taylor Swift's public ticket sale has
been canceled over extreme demand
Ticketmaster says ticket tickets tickets
for Taylor's era's tour will no longer
be put on sale for the general public on
Friday today Ticketmaster said plans
fans blocked to the ticketing website
which is part of Live Nation earlier
this week for the first round of
pre-sale tickets causing site
disruptions and slow cues the site was
only supposed to be open to around 1.5
million verified Taylor Swift fans but
14 million people including Bots hit the
site said the CEO of live nation's
biggest shareholders yesterday
Ticketmaster tweeted due to the
extraordinarily High demands and
ticketing systems and insufficient
remaining ticket inventory to meet that
demand tomorrow's public on sale for
Taylor Swift the errors tour has been
canceled
okay so there's so many things to break
down here first is the CEO of the parent
company of Live Nation and Ticketmaster
went on like GMA or something basically
delivered all these facts you know
enough people signed on during pre-sale
to fill 900 stadiums that's what he said
which is a crazy statistic
um and this is what we were saying
earlier in the week if you had been
required to put in your prefit pre-sale
code into Ticketmaster before getting in
line
1.5 million people would have been in
line as opposed to 14 million people who
had no sort of barrier you could have
went on ticketmaster.com and got there
like it was is it really that simple is
that really the fix like someone really
no offense was that stupid yeah someone
was that stupid first of all that that's
a huge thing
the second thing is is you we never
should have gotten to a place where
General on sale had no inventory left
the point of the pre-sales whether it
was her verified fans or Capital One is
there's an allotted amount maybe it's
like 20 of the tickets go and pre-sale
another 20 go in uh Capital One and then
60 go for the general public on sale so
they there and I'm sure Taylor is
furious that her tickets were never able
to actually go on sale
um because that's not supposed to happen
so that's a huge the fact that they left
no they put up every ticket for sale
during pre-sale is unheard of that's not
a thing like there's a certain
percentage saved for pre-sale and then
general public gets the rest
um I don't think there's zero tickets
left that's an insufficient inventory
insufficient which means very little or
not as much as they should have and also
14 million people sign up for pre-sale
how many people were about to sign on
for general public and they did not have
sufficient tickets I think now they
wanna this is just like my theory I
think they want to pause I think there
will be a public on sale I think they
want to try and get back these tickets
that either Bots or scalpers got maybe
they'll buy them back maybe they'll
cancel those people's orders if they can
verify that they're not real fans well
and then there will be a public on sale
when all of this is sorted that's the
vibe I'm getting like there will be an a
public on sale they're just not ready
today okay that's interesting I hope
that that's the case but you know Live
Nation does work with ticket brokers
scalpers Bots like they do work with
those companies because they get a
kickback for reselling one ticket for 14
Grand you know what I mean that's why
people are so mad at Live Nation and
Ticketmaster because it's like a it's a
dishonest and not transparent way of
doing business
yeah
so I don't know they they stand to lose
a lot to cancel all those orders but
they're getting so much backlash that
like perhaps it'd be worth it I don't
know and they're getting so much
backlash that it's becoming like
political so yeah okay should we give
these tickets back or should we you know
be on the floor of Congress explaining
why we should be able to keep our
company intact right right no no you're
right it's getting political people want
to take this to like the Senate yeah
um because it is a monopoly and it is
like sure try going on tour without
Ticketmaster or Live Nation even
remotely behind you you'll have to play
in a Public Square Live Nation a lot of
people don't realize not only is Live
Nation a promoter they also own venues
most of the venues I perform in are
owned by Live Nation or the promoter
that I'm working with mostly Live Nation
like every Fillmore in the country owned
by Live Nation so many uh different
Arenas like if Taylor would perform
without them she would literally be
performing in Central Park which would
be stunning yeah
um so there's that but then there's also
the element of like what involvement and
level of responsibility Taylor has she
hasn't said anything you know people are
leaving you know writing open letters to
Taylor you know disavowing their their
fan hood and I just think this is a peak
example of toxicity entitlement and like
generally you know unwellness in fan
communities like if you're gonna decide
let's say for you watch this whole Saga
you've seen how Taylor has you know
responded or not responded and you've
decided you no longer want to be a fan
that is completely on you we don't care
we really don't care again this is not
in an airport you do not have to
announce your departure just go quietly
and we really don't [ __ ] care not
only do we not care but if you're gonna
like write an open letter or make a tick
tock of yourself crying um you're really
just exposing yourself as mentally
unwell and now your friends and your
family like know this about you no it's
true and if you went viral then you know
millions of people know this about you
you and you should be embarrassed no and
that's not to say that like you can't
criticize Taylor because this definitely
should have been handled better we don't
know exactly what level of
responsibility or blame we can put on
her and her team but she definitely like
should say something you know so I think
it's okay to be like critical but like
to disavow and no I think okay I think
she should say something like just to
the effect of like oh my God you guys
crashed Ticketmaster like this is crazy
we're doing our best to like figure this
out like thank you for the support I
don't she doesn't need to like apologize
she doesn't need to like do something
about Ticketmaster just like just to she
could say something but if she doesn't
say something like I'm totally fine with
that too by the way same
she doesn't need to say anything
but if she wanted to like she could it
literally doesn't matter it's not gonna
change anything it's just gonna make
people feel better right but I think the
point I'm trying to make the point I'm
trying to make here is like I'm not
saying like you can't be critical of the
situation like sure you want to talk
about it sure but like to cry and write
open letters and start blogs about why
you're not
uh being a Taylor Swift fan anymore is
really like a deeply unwell thing for
you to do and like you need to evaluate
why you are are like that you know
that's more of a you thing than a Taylor
thing yeah
so the the takeaway for me which I think
for a lot of people to take away is like
Ticketmaster Live Nation yeah all of
that but like I'm looking inside our
community of swifties and seeing that
some of you [ __ ] are not okay more
than that if you're willing to be done
with Taylor the music right here she's
giving you the bits and pieces of her
heart on a platter because you didn't
get your ticket you're not a real fan
never
honor is that
um
so I just for anyone wondering still
don't have tickets I'm not worried I
will one thing about me is like if I'm
committed to something like I will find
a way in I will sneak in I will you know
scalp outside like I'll get a ticket
um I know that's not the case for
everyone so if you didn't get a ticket
and you're not gonna get a ticket like
that does suck that totally sucks but it
all sucks you know War famine terminal
illnesses you're okay
also her past few tours have been
recorded and released as specials and
they're really really good and so like
everyone at some point will be able to
see the show even if it's not in the way
that they wanted like
I held last night before bed I watched
reputation World Tour on Netflix and
I've seen it a few times but I haven't
seen it in perhaps years and like you
know I always say like I don't believe
in the reputation hype yada yada but
like it really is like so good
um and I always liked it but like it was
never like a top one of mine but I
watched like the second half of
reputation and I saw like dancing with
your with our hands tied dress king of
my heart this is why we can't have nice
things getaway car don't blame me and I
was like damn like
this album really is that [ __ ] makes
you think and I was like really Ben said
he felt like he was watching
um like he was hanging out with Michaela
like and he put on Moana and like left
the room and she knows all the words and
like she's seen it a hundred times it
was actually like an amazing comparison
because he was like you want to watch
reputation and I was like yeah you are
to Taylor as Kayla is to Moana no
totally except neither kaler nor I like
have toxic ideals when it comes to being
a fan true so this has been like a very
interesting
um like dialogue in just like the
ticketing industry and of course like
something actually does need to change
there's no reason why like
ticket scalpers and Bots get priority
over actual fans like if you want to be
a scalper shirt get in line with
everyone else
yeah it's capitalism you know we can't
stop the scalpers but they shouldn't be
in line before May if we got there at
the same time yeah and they could be in
general public yeah like I'm not against
scalping like people have to make their
living sure galper's got a scalp but at
the very top like Ticketmaster enabling
and prioritizing those scalpers that
ain't right
that ain't right simply yeah
but Taylor I love you if you think this
could be something yeah if you do want
to you know release a statement or talk
about it um at a friendly podcast with
hosted by two fabulous Jewish girls
um of course you're always welcome here
yeah
I know she was just like waiting for
that and now she's just like an
invitation
yeah for sure are you ready for our next
story which is a little book news really
really exciting because Paris Hilton is
ready to share her journey to Icon
status and a billion dollar Empire in
her new Memoir coming out in March
called Paris the memoir
people can exclusively reveal the cover
for the star's upcoming book which
Chronicles her rebellious youth the
abuse she claims to have endured and her
rise to Global super stardom so the
cover this is just like spare a few
weeks ago we got cover title release
date and I'm [ __ ] stoked I mean Paris
has lived many many lifetimes like I
think what I really realized
oh it looks like a magazine it's cute
um I think what what we all realized
when we watched her documentary is like
we really don't know Paris at all and
that was just like a small insight into
her life I mean there's so many eras I
would be so curious to hear about of
course like the Nicole Richie era of
course
um growing up at the Waldorf with Kathy
and Rick like there's so many different
things she's the perfect
um candidate for a book and I think this
is like
this is going to be uh like a Britney
level well Brittany Britney's book we
like reported on Britney's book she got
what like 60 million dollars
I don't remember that doesn't sound
right
oh
let me look I feel like
I barely remember reporting on that book
like I feel like it's not happening no I
remember reporting on it because I had
guessed that she would do a book and she
did
of course
um
actually no apparently it wasn't 60
because I remember being like wait
that's it
yeah that's a lot for like yeah no
you're right maybe one million okay
she'll make more after she outs I think
she will outsell 15 million dollars in
books and then she'll get like a royalty
um who got 60 million maybe it's the
Obamas or something like I don't know
why that was in my brain maybe it was
Prince Harry for his three books oh
Perhaps Perhaps so she got 15. she
deserves more but like this is I feel
like we're now we're gonna like
really get to know everything that went
down in that time period
and but it's funny like we heard about
Britney's book a year ago and like we
don't know a title we don't have a cover
yeah apparently by the way if she
doesn't name it I'm not a girl not yet a
woman like goodbye no she's not gonna
name it that because like she is a woman
now she wrote that like 20 years ago I'm
just trying to find the woman
maybe all I need is time no there are
articles that I've said saw say that
she's done writing her Memoir but it
there's a hold up it's publication date
will apparently be delayed due to a lack
of paper according to TMZ what
eyebrow raise chop I'm sure there's by
the way like a million people who have
to read it I'm sure legal is like all
over it because she's already like in
such a litigious
like moment
um I'm sure she wrote a lot about her
dad
um I think they probably just want to
clear you know double check
they're saying it's because of a printer
shortage but every other book is getting
right it's fun paris's book is out on
time
well I just feel like I'll believe that
book when I see it Brittany yeah
um I think Paris writing a book is
fabulous I think that's really my
takeaway from her documentary was like
we need more yeah
I feel like it's going to be similar to
Jessica Simpson's in the sense of like
seeing Paris like we've never seen her
before even though she's been sharing a
lot she has a reality show she had a
documentary she has a podcast like she
is really sharing in every medium
there's something about a book that
really cuts to the heart of the matter
unlike all those other formats
especially from someone who was at the
center multiple times of like the most
iconic moments in pop culture history
and like we'll never really know what
that was like
yeah her book is going to be released
under Day Street books which is an
imprint of William Morrow and they did
Kelly Ripa Gabrielle Union and Dave
Grohl's books so good stuff all star
cast all star cast but if I was writing
a book right now like whoever published
uh
Jessica Simpson like that's where I
would go
I would be seeing publisher same
Ghostwriter same title same content
inside same cover cover everything same
promotional 100
yeah we just open book the sequel right
open book two yeah anyways I can't wait
to read this March should be here sooner
than we know it yeah and I hope that it
is as Illuminating as we hope that it's
going to be that'll be a good book
mm-hmm are you ready for our next story
some sad news Al Roker was hospitalized
with blood clots in his leg and lungs
during his Today Show absence our worker
revealed he has been hospitalized for
blood clots in his legs and lungs after
sparking concern over his Today Show
absence he said on Instagram so many of
you have been thoughtfully asking where
I've been last week I was admitted to
the hospital with a blood clot in my leg
which sent some clots into my lungs
after some medical whack-a-mole I am so
fortunate to be getting terrific medical
Medical Care and on the way to recovery
he thanked his fans for their well
wishes and prayers and said hope to see
you soon have a great weekend did he say
anything like I know obviously his
health is most important but did he say
anything about the Thanksgiving Day
Parade
he didn't
I don't want it
I feel like
he could make it
I feel like you could make it too if you
take the same time I mean obviously I
don't want to put pressure on him but
like if he takes the time for himself
like I think that he could do it if he
could do it and I know obviously like
his health is is number one priority
here but like
I can't remember a Thanksgiving Day
Parade coverage that I watched that
didn't have Val Roker
yeah wow I'm gonna be watching the
parade this year because we are up at
those hours
this is going to be like the first time
in a while I sometimes catch a tail end
of the parade it's a dog show but like
Harry's gonna watch the parade you know
and they're gonna want to watch it I
have to say your girl is gonna watch the
parade I'm gonna say who are these
people up here I have to say we watched
um every year growing up and it is by
far like my favorite childhood tradition
like I want my kids to watch it Harry
has to watch it Kayla has to watch it
like Coco melon will be there you know
I'm sure there's like a big uh Moana
float like all the kids favorites let's
look at what the lineup is Thanksgiving
Day Parade
2022
lineup it's like I mean the performers
like it's one thing
once I learned like at the age of 14
that nobody was singing live like the
magic was truly lost for me and it's
never really been the same I don't know
why they can't just have people perform
like with their vocals but it's kind of
like a circus
here are the performers big lineup Adam
DeVine Sarah Hyland and flu laborg are
performing uh together from Pitch
Perfect Bumper in Berlin there's a new
Pitch Perfect movie about Adam Devine's
character coming out Betty who will be
performing icon
Big Time Rush wow they're still around
they are Tick Tock brought them back to
life Blanco Brown okay
cam your girl I love cam so far I know
I'm five for five on knowing everyone
Dionne Warwick details coming soon
Fitz and the Tantrums okay I'm gonna say
this is the first one I don't know but I
look forward to being
moved by them they also co-headlined a
tour with Andy Grammer which means that
they're an Andy Grammar Vibe which is a
vibe that I subscribe to mm-hmm Gloria
Sasha and Emily Estefan so Gloria
Estefan girls yeah they have a red table
talk
yes they do
Jordan Sparks she's so thinks Chella
she's literally like you know how um
Mariah Carey is like the queen of
Christmas like she only wakes up on
November 1st like I'm telling you Jordan
Sparks wakes up on November 23rd like
I'm here yeah
Joss Stone throwback
Kirk Franklin I think we got the gist
Miss America
Paula Abdul
okay
Sean Paul okay
very impressed I think that um
if you're like going to be home on
Thanksgiving like there's nothing better
than like waking up with the kids and
watching like that's my favorite
tradition I hope everyone can Implement
that in their house
I hope so too and the floats it looks
like they made some new ones I feel like
the floats look a little Dusty sometimes
well so that's the time to retire that
float that's the thing about the floats
it's like they really don't have that
long of a shelf life and some characters
for sure are like
Eternal and forever in our hearts but
like it is time to perhaps retire the
Snoopy one you know what I mean even
though it's cool it's so Christmas he's
he's great but we need like updated
floats they really don't keep well in no
things and they like sit in a warehouse
in Brooklyn for a year and then somebody
comes dusts it off and puts it on a
bunch of strings it's turn yeah so I
want premium squeaky clean floats that's
what I want me too like brand new shiny
yeah relevant characters but not too fad
worthy you know right no it's not trendy
it's classic it's classic it's a fine
line but I expect Macy's to walk it I
expect them to walk it well every year
walk it no flowers
I feel like probably one of the coolest
things about living on the upper west
side if you live in that part of town is
like having an apartment that looks onto
the parade like that's really sick yeah
I never have been in an apartment like
I've never been invited to like that
Russia and on Thanksgiving morning
but you went to one Thanksgiving event
that was like on the west side where you
could see the parade yeah but like out
on the street which is cool but like I'd
like to be sitting by a fireplace
sipping eggnog looking down through the
window you know
okay if it makes you feel better I don't
think that actually is achieved because
like one if you're in an apartment with
a fireplace like wow that's rare there's
not that many so one but then like the
fireplace isn't right next to the window
so you're either sitting by the fire or
you're standing by the window I'm
telling you there's one apartment like
the the ideal like the situation that
I'm envisioning like big huge old
windows okay right maybe you're not
super high up like right you need to
kind of be like street level right like
fifth or sixth floor so you can see the
people and
the things and I'm sitting by the couch
the couch is right by the window and
then right across from the couch is a
fireplace and perhaps a butler or
something but but the fireplace like
really can't be within the windows you
know it needs a chimney it has to be on
a wall yeah across from me I thought you
said the windows are across from you no
no I'm sitting by the window the couch
is by the window oh okay cool cool and
it's a big sectional maybe I'm in the
corner
the Luca sectional from Z Gallery or the
yeah or the cloud couch from Restoration
Hardware like that is privilege okay
like one of those apartments yeah and if
you have one please invite Claudia to
your Thanksgiving Festival I have to say
like The Toasters who are like all from
different walks of life whenever I say
like I want they owe it someone will be
like yeah no my uncle lives come the
amount of people who have seriously
offered me face value tickets are like
we have an extra ticket come with us we
live in it's a lot of people in like
Atlanta and Tampa which are shows I was
not playing I got invited to a box in
Atlanta I got invited to a box
um in maybe Tampa
they were like we are just charging like
you can hold like 25 people they're like
we're just charging everyone we bought
it and we're gonna fill it with 25
people so if you want to come let me
know and I was like okay
I'll keep that she's like she's like
we're really fun like we love Taylor
we're cool like we'll drink and I'm like
okay well I think I saw the same message
no I got so many offers for like good I
was actually gonna send it to you but
then I was like there's no way that I
got this and you didn't so yeah no so
the thing is for me I have options so
not to like brag but like I'll be fine
yeah but like I think it's different
when someone invites you to like their
apartment like on the upper west side to
watch the parade versus like their Uncle
like the uncle's a little it's a little
weird also also like not that I'm trying
to overstay my welcome like if you were
to invite me um to like come watch a
parade from your gorgeous mansion on
Central Park West I would need to spend
the weekend because getting to and from
your apartment on the day of the parade
is just it's not worth it
yeah well I sneezed I mean if you were
open to um
taking a horse and carriage you could
just take one through the park I'm not
open and then back
no I'm not open it's the easiest way to
cross town on Thanksgiving no if someone
just invited me to spend the weekend
like that would work for me but you
don't like to spend that much time in
places actually you're kind of like in
and out yeah no I'm so in and out one
thing I know about myself I stay till
the end of the parade I think it was
Justin Sylvester who like posted like a
poll and it was like if you say you're
just gonna stop by a party like to say
hi and show your face how long are you
staying
if I if I'm saying like I'm just
stopping by to show to say hi 30 minutes
oh that's funny me like five
just to prove that I was there and then
they'll be like oh she was running
around I didn't see her but they don't
know I'm in the cab no I wouldn't go out
of my way to go somewhere to be there
for five minutes I wouldn't want to stay
longer and torture myself I feel like 30
minutes is fair I can talk to a few
people have a snack go no five minutes
for me I thought it was an interesting
question
yeah what was the consensus uh I don't
know I never I never came back for the
results
are you ready for our next story is it
the next story that's brought to you by
Spirit Society yes
now that we've officially entered the
holiday season it's time to talk about
sports society's biggest Savings of the
Year Black Friday have you been waiting
for the perfect time to try Sports
Society or do you just want to stock up
for the holidays well the moment has
finally arrived as a member of our
amazing beautiful stunning and smart
Community we're giving you an exclusive
look into the Big Black Friday plans
Spritz Society on Black Friday will be
25 off the entire site yes that's 25 the
biggest savings you will ever see on
their iconic sparkling cocktails as you
guys know our code toast is 10 25 is
huge and if you wanna you know you're
hosting people for the holidays and you
want to stock up that's a great time if
you're ordering a bunch to save 25
that'll be huge savings or if you
haven't tried it yet and we're not
available in your state and you've been
like reticent to try online now is the
perfect time to do it because Black
Friday 25 off is
is huge so the Black Friday sale is
coming up and you can sign up to be the
first to know when the sale goes live
um so if you go to the sports Society
Instagram bio uh go to at Spritz
s-p-r-i-t-z get the link in their bio
you'll sign up today to be the first in
the no ones when Black Friday launches
so again go to the Lincoln bio at the
Spritz Instagram which is Spritz
um Lincoln bio sign up and then you'll
be the first to know about the Big Black
Friday plans which
it's kind of secondary sickening can't
wait Spritz is going to go really well
I'm making like I'm gonna make a
Thanksgiving Spritz cocktail oh like in
a picture yeah like a nice festive
cocktail but also like using Spritz will
make it take half the work energy
Etc so keep you posted on that check my
ID for more do tell I will
our next story means nothing to us but
everything to a lot of people Ellen
Pompeo is leaving Gray's Anatomy and she
is immense gratitude for the fans as
Meredith gray is readying to leave
Seattle
Ellen Pompeo was thankful for all 19
seasons of Gray's Anatomy the actress
also known as Meredith gray I guess she
is the anatomy in which they are
speaking no actually I think I thought
that once too
no no it is how does I think it's a
different spelling no e-y-e-y I thought
the hospital was called like Gray's
Seattle Grace
it's not Grace Anatomy
oh Grace as in graciousness
it's Gray's Anatomy as in Meredith Grace
is anatomy so she's like the main
character
yeah well now she's not because she uh
sent a sweet goodbye message on
Instagram to fans after the fall finale
last week marked her official final
episode of the Season she said I'm
eternally grateful and humbled by the
love and support you all have shown me
Meredith Gray
she capitalized gray and the show for 19
Seasons through it all none of it would
have been possible without the best fans
in the world including Becca Tilly and
Tanya radd our writers and you have all
have made the ride so fun and iconic I
also see now she does capitalize random
words so take the gray with the grain of
salt okay wait okay so I guess I never
really put together that Ellen pompeo's
character like was the main [ __ ] in the
show and like the show was named after
her so like so the show's over right
sorry like how do you make a show that
would be like you know Selena Meyer not
being in Veep when the show was called
Veep and she's the vice president no
that's it this is actually worse than
that yeah I know I'm trying to think of
like a a similar
this would be
I can't think right now
if the Kardashians exited the
Kardashians right so the show is over
honestly like it's time like nothing
good is meant to last this long honestly
and I feel like the Heyday of Grays was
like McDreamy mcsteemy I don't know but
then like everyone died
um and like a lot of like the the OG
players left like 10 years ago
so I don't know what's been going on at
the hospital since all those people left
but like I don't wanna know in the words
of the lady in the back seat of the taxi
for The Lion King commercial each is
time
it is time I hope I mean no offense to
everyone like the show needs to end this
should be the end of the show I'm sure
they'll keep it going for a few more
seasons people are still gonna watch P
like the show is a soap opera at this
point with like 40 Seasons I guess
that's fine for it but like that's a
little wild that gray is gone from
Gray's Anatomy no totally and like it is
kind of crazy that like she stayed on
for so long after the show was like
the show was over like years ago
I know all I think about when I think
about the show is Becca and Tanya and I
actually need to go check their
Instagrams and see are they okay yeah
um I also think when I think of Ellen
Pompeo was the time uh Becca Tilly like
ran into her on the plane and she said
no to taking a photo with Becca
really but I thought that they've had
her on the podcast
I don't know
Becca said she wasn't rude she was just
like with her kids and like overwhelmed
uh it's overwhelming yeah so Becca
didn't say it in a negative way but I
just think about that
I didn't hear that one maybe I'm like
literally making this up but I swear no
that's just our Becca Tilly Geeks out
over flying with Ellen Pompeo yeah get
tweeted
um if I asked for a pic will that go
well for me
she never felt so safe with Meredith
gray LOL I'm watching Gray's Anatomy if
she walks by and sees this I'll Beam
with pride
no that's all spider that's also what I
think of
I don't know if she ever asked for the
picture Okay so maybe she asked the
husband to be polite and he said it
wasn't a great idea because the kids
were there okay sounds like it was a
very totally fine exchange yeah
um so I'm sorry for all the gray girlies
that this time is over but maybe it's
time to pick up another show like I
think it's been time for quite some time
so it's definitely time now
yeah try Game of Thrones there's a ton
of Seasons now they have the prequel
yeah this shot yeah give it a shot
are you ready for a fifth and final
story for the final story for the fifth
and final episode of the week yeah it is
Denise richards's car was shot out while
driving with her husband in a road rage
incident this story is so crazy Denise
and her husband Aaron's car was shot out
during a road rage incident on Monday in
LA but the couple is okay Aaron was
chauffeuring the actress to a film
studio when the male driver behind them
got irritated that they were having a
hard time finding the place TMZ reported
on Tuesday the outlet claimed that Aaron
let the upset upset driver who was
allegedly shouting at them while trying
to squeeze in front of their car pass
them that's when the driver allegedly
shot at Aaron and Denise's vehicle
striking the back end on the driver's
side TMZ obtained a photo of the Bullet
Hole in the cup oh my God then also a
Paparazzi got photos of Denise crying on
the phone after the shooting incident
yeah of course
crazy distressed yo people in this
country and tree are not okay and I
if you if you've ever been in a car with
me like you know like I actually really
do suffer from road rage like people are
genuinely moronic and terrible at
driving but like this is so
unwell this person is so sick for this
first of all you never know who's in a
car like there could be kids even if
there's not kids it's not okay to kill
there's human lives right but like Jesus
[ __ ] Christ and animal lives no it's
disgusting now of course the Bravo
fandom has spiraled from this new story
because do you remember when Aaron went
to the dinner party and was trying to
explain to everybody what he did for a
living and said that he grew up next to
like a nuclear waste facility and he has
crazy information on how to treat cancer
but like he can't even talk about it
because there's so many people after him
and there they follow him right so a lot
of people are speculating whether this
incident is being you know masked as
road rage when it's actually nuclear
waste facility cancer research
bodyguards
now it's not it's possible
light to like speculate over someone's
traumatic incident even though exactly I
feel like that's not it's not
speculating like I I feel like Aaron
would say
Aaron would be the first to say if it
was right right maybe we'll maybe yeah
maybe and who who said was road rage TMZ
right right except that Aaron did say
like that he was trying to let them pass
right I don't know no this is really so
scary like honestly so scary also like
you don't actually have road rage
because this is road rage like people
literally look at each other over road
rage I just saw a story yesterday of
this nurse who was shot in a road rage
incident like I guess it was like two
drivers were raging and she was like
shot not even a part of it as a passer
buyer as a passerby and then like
there's a trial going on I saw the story
came up because like the nurse's dad
like lunged at her daughter's killer
because she was so enraged yeah as he
should yeah
oh my God I literally hate this country
sometimes like collectively we are so
not okay like everyone but with each day
that passes we are all becoming more and
more unwell I relate to my fellow man
less and less like I walk on the street
I'm like I don't [ __ ] relate to any
of you morons like everyone is so
I don't want to keep saying not okay
because it's not even a strong enough
word
yeah I agree and there's like really
nothing happening to make it better help
people no this is terrible like just
wielding guns on the 405 for no [ __ ]
reason except for the only uniting force
in this country which is the [ __ ]
toast the [ __ ] toast I was gonna say
this and maybe if everyone started their
day I'm not even kidding if everyone
started the day with a little toast
maybe you wouldn't be so angry maybe no
because I feel like I feel like this is
what it is honestly I feel like a lot of
media and just like people leave their
houses and are constantly confronted by
things that are like making them soft
like we're we're tailoring everything to
everyone's needs and the trigger
warnings and I'm not blaming this whole
thing on trigger warnings but I'm just
saying like we live in a society that's
like constantly catering to people's
every want and desire and it's like no
sometimes you're not gonna be confronted
by something that you want right and so
when you are confronted by adversity you
know maybe conflict you don't know how
to handle it because you've been coddled
I think one it's that and I think two
it's like the media that people consume
is so targeted to make them crazy to
make them scared to make them fear their
fellow man and it's making for a
dastardly environment no Etc it's so
divisive and here at the toast we're
gonna tell you the hard things like
you're crying over Taylor Swift tickets
like you need help we're gonna tell you
the hard things and we're also going to
unite the people we unite the people the
media is dividing dividing us like
making and even like with coven making
everyone's afraid of each other yeah no
we need to make we need to make the
toast like the official special Morning
Show of America because the people so we
can begin to heal
I I think that's a beautiful note to end
on seriously and if you're already
listening to this episode you're part of
the solution you're part of the solution
and if you want to be even a bigger part
of the solution like tell a friend about
the time
share it at your Thanksgiving dinner
like if you can convert one or two
people by the end of the year and we
will all you know the audience will
double in size like we will be well on
our way to Healing mclart speaking of we
need to do our annual Thanksgiving table
conversations episode
every year Claudia and I do a patreon
episode that's always requested and it's
so good it's a fast five stories that
you need to know to bring to your
Thanksgiving table so it's interesting
stories from the biz news World art it's
like they're not gonna be they're not
celebrities they're not divisive and
they're not celebrity stories it's like
actual interesting stories and news that
you can share with your family to Foster
interesting conversation that people
shouldn't be that won't make everyone
like clench their buttholes like student
debt like we're not talking about that
like we're not going to be bringing up
topics that you know grandpa and uncle
are going to go but you know what you
know what we'll have to do a big brief
on we'll have to do our research
ourselves FTX
yes I need to learn more about what's
going on in crypto because that's a
great Thanksgiving conversation starter
great Thanksgiving combo where did oh I
know all I know is something is a mess
where did the money go find out at
patreon.com we're gonna get the answers
we're gonna blow this case wide open
um
so that is our show that was a fabulous
week here at the toast thank you all for
being a part of it and thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
Millennium Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know everyone to Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
at the podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that Spotify iTunes digital
public video I have radio guest packs
all the places so maybe listen to
podcast find us the toaster leave a
five-star review about how wickedly
talented we are have an amazing weekend
you guys we'll see you tomorrow for the
last three episodes before Thanksgiving
so reminder Monday Tuesday Wednesday
next week episodes no Thursday Friday
and if you haven't gotten your toast
merch yet make sure to do that at
toastmerch.com our holiday collection
just dropped slippers pajamas sweaters
Christmas ornaments all the things at
toastmerch.com have a great weekend
bye